I really want to say a huge thank you to
all our periodic video viewers who've
sent us wishes of goodwill over the last
few days after the 20 million pound
building was completely destroyed by
fire most of you by now have probably
heard that there was a huge fire in
nottingham and the evening of September
the 12th which completely destroyed
the new chemistry building that we're
building our carbon neutral chemistry
lab this is on the separate campus from
our main chemistry building and is
designed to be an example of how new
chemistry buildings could look for the
future and sadly when it was about 70%
built it caught fire
we have no idea yet the cause of the
fire but sadly the whole building was
destroyed and the university has already
said we're going to rebuild it again but
we were really pleased because we had so
many messages not only from chemists
from around the world but from you our
viewers
that really warmed the hearts of me and
the rest of the periodic videos team but
especially Pete license Pete of the
green lab coat who was or still is the
director of our carbon neutral lab
project and obviously for him it was a
terribly sad evening but seeing your
messages and hearing what you've said
has really cheered him up and already
we're all feeling very positive about
the future the building was completely
empty there was nobody there
no one was hurt and there was no
research going on so we haven't lost any
work and the operation of our chemistry
department is completely unaffected
apart from the fact that there were
research groups who were planning to
move into the lab when it was finished
so it's completely business as usual as
students are unaffected and in fact
everybody is in a really determined mood
so things may be even better
than usual for our students it's far too
early to know the cause when I left
Nottingham a couple of days ago the site
was still smoking and hot but there were
no chemicals in the building where I
should say there were no research
chemicals because everything in the
world is made that of chemicals but
there were no chemicals that were being
used for experiments in the building
there were some explosions which you can
see on the videos of the fire so we're
not sure what that is then maybe gas
cylinders or something like that that
were used by the builders but so far we
don't know what is the cause of course
there will be a proper investigation the
cause of the fire will be established
before any new building work starts
because if there were any ways that the
design can be improved we'll do it I
drove past the fire when it was about 2
hours after it started though I had seen
it earlier because there are webcams or
there were webcams monitoring the
building so you could see the fire on
the webcams and it was extraordinary the
fire was so intense that it more or less
blotted out the webcams and because
webcams are sensitive the infrared light
everything looked almost white but it
was a huge fire and terribly sad but
when I drove past the whole building was
well ablaze and the roof had largely
disappeared and it's the biggest fire
I've ever seen but I suppose one of the
saddest sights I've ever seen as well
but the important thing is really to say
that out of these ashes are going to
come something that's even better and
will be more valuable to science across
the world